yesterday we saw closing statements in
the derek chauvin trial in minnesota
this is the trial of the police officer
who killed george floyd in the case that
last summer
catalyzed nationwide protests we may
soon
know the verdict but in the meantime
it's even conceivable by the time we
publish this clip we will know the
verdict although it doesn't seem to be
moving
quite so quickly but in the meantime
what we know for sure
is that derek shovin's lawyer eric
nelson gave a completely
deranged and delusional closing
statement that in a sense
actually felt trumpian in the way that
trump pushed the presidency to new lows
eric nelson pushed legal defense to new
lows
with this ridiculous closing statement
here is eric nelson
saying that there are elements of
criminal trials that are like
chocolate chip cookies yes take a look
the criminal case is kind of like baking
chocolate chip cookies
you have to have the necessary
ingredients you've got to have
flour and sugar and butter and chocolate
chips
whatever else goes into those chocolate
chip cookies
if you have all of the ingredients you
can make chocolate chip cookies
but if you're missing any one single
ingredient
you can't make chocolate chip cookies
it's a simple kind of
analogy but the criminal law works the
same way
we say the ingredient called the
ingredients the elements
the state has the burden of proving each
and every element beyond a reasonable
doubt
not only is it bizarre it's also wrong
like you can make chocolate chip cookies
often without any one ingredient you
might think well i definitely need flour
no you can use flour alternatives well
okay but i need eggs
no you can use applesauce as an
emulsifier instead of eggs okay but
butter i definitely need
no you can replace butter with any
number of lubricating elements oils
of different kinds it's just a very dumb
analogy but
sadly it may be one that is fine-tuned
to what eric nelson perceives to be the
level of the jury we just don't know
that's the scary part
this may actually work i've talked
before about my jury duty experience on
an assault case
and the most infuriating part
was nobody uh i would want to say nobody
almost no one in the jury room even
understood what it was we were
adjudicating it was a question of
was a physical altercation self-defense
by the accused and by self-defense we
don't mean
you know backyard bar rules of what
constitutes self-defense we were
supposed to adjudicate this case on the
basis of
the judge's instructions as to what
legally
self-defense is did it meet the required
legal elements for self-defense
and the conversation in the jury room
among everybody other than myself and
one other juror
was a colloquial discussion of now come
on this was self-defense well but hold
on a second
at the time i lived in massachusetts
what is massachusetts law about a right
to retreat
what anyway the point was on something
that simple
two-thirds of the jurors didn't even
understand the law
meant to be adjudicated i'm not hugely
optimistic
uh about any particular jury i know
nothing about the derrick chauvin case
uh jury but based on my experience i'm
skeptical
here's another portion of the closing
where eric nelson says
if you were talking you were breathing
therefore since george floyd was saying
i can't breathe
it means his breathing is fine which has
already been debunked by dr martin tobin
a pulmonologist who testified during the
case take a look
it's true if you are talking you are
breathing
doesn't mean effectively and dr tobin
described how even medical doctors
have problems sometimes assessing the
legitimacy of a patient's needs
relevant to their respiratory processes
because they're saying i can't breathe
and some doctors confuse it for just
anxiety or this
or that so if medical doctors make these
mistakes
dr tobin told you it provides a false
sense of security
right lieutenant mursel told you that
that is what is said
among police officers he's the trainer
so how many times do we hear an officer
say
based on his training and experience if
you can breathe
you can talk if you can talk you can
breathe excuse me
and then nelson goes directly from this
into the claim that very often people in
custody will
fake a medical emergency to avoid going
to prison now this seems particularly
bogus since george floyd
really did die is the argument that
because other people have faked medical
emergencies
derrick chauvin did nothing wrong in his
handling of floyd
i think that's what he's trying to imply
at least take a look at this video
a reasonable police officer will take
into consideration
again his training his experience
right lieutenant murciel talked about
and many people
talked about many of the officers talked
about how it is not
uncommon for suspects
to feign or pretend to have
a medical emergency to avoid being
arrested unfortunately
that is the reality nobody likes to get
arrested and reasonable police officers
know that
you know these hypotheticals for me
aren't doing much
but it's possible that they're doing
something for the jury we just don't
know yet and then lastly here's derek
shovin's attorney eric nelson saying
listen derek chauvin could have kicked
george floyd
he could have punched george floyd he
could have elbowed george floyd
but he didn't almost like the argument
is
he deserves an award because he didn't
kill
and elbow george floyd he merely killed
him
and i guess that's to be looked up at
too take a look
officer chauvin made a decision not to
use higher levels of force
when he would have been authorized to do
that including punches
kicks elbows right all of these
tools were available to officer shogun
that is not an intent to purposefully
use unlawful force all right and then
actually the very last one
here is eric nelson saying listen george
floyd being put
face down that can't be a problem
because people do really nice things
face down sometimes people sleep face
down
sometimes people sun tan face down so
therefore being face down can't possibly
be
part of this case we've heard a lot
about the prone position
consider just the basic prone position
people sleep in the prom position people
sun tan in the prone position
people get massages in the prone
position the prone position in and of
itself
is not an inherently dangerous act it is
not an
inherently dangerous act so this is the
idea and this is a common legal strategy
take each piece and say that's not a
problem
prone position isn't a problem by itself
knee to the neck isn't a problem by
itself a plus you know derek chauvin
didn't punch george floyd he didn't
elbow george floyd but the point
is all together it is a big deal
everything together killed george floyd
period
and that is what is ultimately being
adjudicated here i really couldn't tell
you how this is going to end up we're
left to wait
there is tension in minnesota in advance
of the verdict
concerns about unrest and to be clear
derek chauvin
is innocent until proven guilty don't
send me the voicemails about oh david
you're looking to hang this guy first of
all i'm against the death penalty i'm
not looking to hang anybody
and of course derek shoving is innocent
until proven guilty
he deserves competent defense counsel
like everyone else full stop there's no
qualifier
the closing statement just happens to be
nonsense
but that doesn't mean it will not work
maybe eric nelson is a [ __ ] but maybe
eric nelson
accurately has assessed what will appeal
to this
jury and that may be the chocolate chip
cookie analogy
we will know when we get the verdict let
me know what you expect you can find me
on twitter
at deepakman one of our sponsors today
is sheath underwear the weather is
warming up and as many of us
know that can be associated with
sticking
rubbing chafing with traditional
underwear
sheath underwear creates boxer briefs
that solve
it all sheath underwear was developed by
a us soldier who spent time deployed in
the desert
he was looking for a way to be more
comfortable and he designed something
that's great
even just for everyday use sheath boxer
briefs have
multiple ergonomic compartments in front
to prevent skin on skin contact
keeping everything separate cool dry
and comfortable so sheath underwear will
prevent the sweatiness
and the chafing and the readjusting and
sheath underwear is giving the david
pakman show audience 20
off when you go to sheath underwear dot
com slash
pacman and use the promo code pacman
my experience with sheath underwear has
been great
yours will be as well if you give it a
try the link is right underneath this
video don't forget to use that promo
code pacman
for 20 off